*laughing* *Ken's Awesome Moves*
*such epic fight*
*oh my....*
*pewds lines up his pool stick*
*Pewds looks for approval but finds none*
How's it going bros, and welcome to pool
*Pewds breaks his pool thing*
*Pewds realizes he sucks at pool*
*takes off le shades*
Alright m8 420 soo dank check me out bruh 1 v 1 club penguin m8
Let's get into this pool business m8 suh dank u know what im sayin fam
Ken is sucking
*Pewds is surprised* Oh wow!
atempts to fix head set
*Ken approaches with a dog ass in hand*
*Pewds likes the dog ass*
*Ken's rape face*
*Pewds smells the dog ass*
Pewds: What is this? *secretly smells ass and enjoys it  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
*Pewds tries to act disgusted* Oh!
Pewds: You fucking dick! (bring that dog ass back tho)
Pewds *tries to cover up his dog ass fetish* That is disgusting!
Wise words from Pewds: Holy shit
it's like i'm at the club
What happened over there?
Pewds: There's bitches in da club.
Pewds: What up, *I don't know.*
Ken: *Da fuq?*
*high pitched noi---oh my ears are bleeding.*
Pewds: Oh ok, so you can move--Oh my god!
Pewds: Hai guys :^)
Pewds: Hey! How's it going guys?
Pewds: Oh man....this thing just went straight for I--*laughs*
Pewds: This is fuckin' weir--*laughs more*
Ken: *You Ok?*
Pewds: Aw hell yeah!
Pewds: Welcome to teh future.
Pewds: Alright we gotta work together as a team.
Pewds: Alright? Ok here we go.
Pewds: Alright, you gotta put my arm around me.
*You two have a.....relationship goin on?*
Pewds: Alright line that shit up for me.
Pewds: LINE THAT SHIT UP.
Pewds: Make sure you don't *inaudible*
Pewds: BONG! *realizing he didn't hit the ball.*
*laughter*
*ooh  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *
*cheering*
*still cheering  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *
Pewds: You see that ladies???
Pewds: You see that?
Pewds: You like this girls? You like shi--*please stahp*
???: Here we GO(ku)
*cheering*
*Hulk*
Pewds: Yeah drink baby. Aw yeah you like that shit?
Both: AWWW....
*RAIG TABLEE but sadly fails*
*laughs*
Pewds: What the fuck just happened? *You fell*
*Pewds calm down jesus...*
*Pewds is having a meltdown*
*What is even going on here...*
*screaming*
*dat booty  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *
Ken: Damn! Pewds: WHOAHOHOHOHO...
Pewds: Marzia, that was a misclick.
Pewds: Oh my god, there's dominos!
Pewds: WELL DONE! NAILED IT!
*complimenting*
*Now Ken's turn*
Ken: *Mocking Pewdiepie* HEY EVERYBODIE!!111! IT PEWDIEPEI
Ken: HEUHEUHEUHEUEHUEHUE
Pewds: *Da fuq man*
Pewds: Fuck you. Ken: Fuck you.
*laughs*
Ken: Alright, so what would be in a good situation. We got a BALL, a TENNIS RACKET
*I don't know. Play tennis?*
Ken: FUCK YOU! FUCK YOU!
Ken: Fuck you!
Pewds: Oh my god, Ken! Ken: WOOOOOOO
Ken: WOOOOOO!!!!
Ken: The fuck is that? Pewds: That's your selfie stick dude.
Pewds: You just threw it away.
*Oooh a fite!*
Pewds: Alright, let's play tennis together. *snickers*
*cheering*
Ken: Hue......Hue...
Pewds: YEAH!!!!!
Pewds: Alright give me a god one.
*Pewds tries to get the ladies but it doesn't work*
*Ok, what the hell is going on here?*
*JUST DO IT.*
*Has Pewds gone thug life?*
*laughter*
Pewds: Alright, KEN.
Pewds: This bullshit has been going on for too long.
Pewds: *inaudible*...left and right
Pewds: I think it's time that you and I...
*Such lightsaber very star wars*
Pewds: Have a fight to the death.
Pewds: Wait...You CAN DRAW DICKS?!
* ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *
Pewds: Hey. They touched.
Pewds: The tips tou--AH..
Pewds: Aw....yeah....so hot. *Lightsaber sex?*
*Yeah it is.*
*Magic.*
Pewds: Oh shit. It's General... *sweet lightsaber moves, Ken*
*Ok now it jus turned weird.*
*Weirdmaggedon in here alright.*
*laughter* Pewds: Are you even doing anything?
Pewds: That's a great flashlig--
Pewds: OOOHOOOHHOHO.....*rip pewds*
Star Wars: Weirdmaggedon 4 confirmed?*
Pewds: AAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHH!!! *Oh shit*
Pewds: AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHH...*You alright Pewds?*
Pewds: FUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK!
Ken: *Hehehheehhe...I'm still killing you  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Pewds: Why did know one tell me...
Pewds: ......There is a fucking jab?!
* ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *
Pewds: I can sense where they're coming from.
Pewds: I feel like a fucking badass right now, guys.
*final showdown.*
Pewds I got the high ground!
*pulls chair*
Pewds: YOU WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE BALANCED TO THE FORCE.
Ken: *But I must......*
*Star Wars scene* Pewds: YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO BE MY BROTHER, KEN!!!!!!
*dramatic flip*
Pewds: Dude that was awesome.
Ken: You like that?
Pewds: UNLIMITED POWERRRRRRRRRR
Ken: Oh no! My leg! *really Ken?*
Ken: I'M MELTING!! AAAH
Pewds: Dicks on you, ya bish!
Ken: *dying noises*
Ken: *Still agonizing about his death*
*Ken.......NOoOoOoOoOoOo*
*Pewds....how could you?*
Pewds: This has been Steam VR 5 with CinnamonToastKen.
Pewds: Go ahead and check out Ken. We'll leave a link in the description.
Pewds: Thank you so much for joining us today.
Pewds: And as always....
*OH SHIT THE FIGHT ISN'T OVER* Pewds: DID I TELL YOU TO GET UP?!
*ending death scene of Ken*
Pewds: Subscribes. *Brofist*
*Oh wat dis now*
*Oh such suspense..Very scared*
*Can't wait for Star Wars 5: The Porno Menace.*
*To be Continued...*